hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
the first today we have Kath McNamara
with us she's a superhero on the CW
you've seen her in the the arrow in the
shadows in all of it she cannot be
stopped also she has an incredibly
genius brain to humble brag about her
brain she graduated high school at 14
graduated college at 17 so try not to
feel insecure in this beautiful color
section with Kat McNamara turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a website all by yourself
but if you get stuck they have 24/7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help you out so head to
Squarespace comm such grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain I'm so thankful that you're here
one also the pink hair looks great on
you thank you very much well what is
this it's for an upcoming project oh
okay yeah that's not a personal choice
it's a project choice no I actually I
always say this I am I I have no courage
when it comes to my own hair in in
making crazy choices but if it's for a
job I will do just about anything yeah
literally I actually really hope at some
point in my career I have to shave my
head for a role just because I know I'll
never do it for myself have you had
those fantasy actress dreams of doing
the cry in a mirror shaving your head
manifesting that for you today first I
think there's stuff in the future okay
in looking you up and researching you
and not to be like a stalker or creep
stop are you exhausted because your
whole life story via the internet which
I want to talk about like wow that's
different than what your actual life
story is you should be asleep right now
that you do so much I'll tell you my
secret what is it coffee and
stubbornness and stubbornness yes okay
is that a type of sugar no I truly I've
also I've never needed much sleep in my
life it's just kind of how I made I
guess which I'm okay with
I mean he seems like you have a very
active and functional brain so that
probably never falls asleep at night
maybe never fully I don't actually know
but truly I might I'm two things that I
really care about and that mean a lot to
me and things that I want to be doing
yeah so if I have to get out about it
four or five in the morning to get them
done I'm gonna do it it's it's so
worthwhile to me well in my research of
you one you're a complete Brainiac you
are an amazing actress you are an
amazing musician you were also an
amazing selfie taker you have what I
call like selfie hands selfie arms right
you have a selfie stick as an arm on
your Instagram I loved it so much that
you like I always get tasked with taking
selfies because I have long limbs mm-hmm
and I feel like you've just dominated
that whole field but then you understand
you have selfie stick arms too but my
arms are disproportionately long for my
body as are my legs so it's not in this
era it's the perfect time to have long
arms like okay I want to go back to the
beginning I want to talk about so you're
from Kansas City and then take me
through Kansas City to graduating high
school at 14 to going to Drexel at 17
talk me through that period so I I'm
from a family of science and medical
professionals so education is education
has always been very important in my
family and a huge priority and I thought
I was the black sheep of the family when
I wanted to be an economist how many
siblings do you have none none okay but
everybody from my my mom to my
great-aunts to my grandmother
grandfather great-grandmother girls
everybody's all science and medicine and
there was me who decided she wanted to
do economics yeah until I became an
actor and then that just was a total
other level of departing from the family
line yeah but I I had an amazing
educational kind of perspective as a kid
due to my family but also due to one of
my first teachers and I'm still friends
with her to this day and she's just one
of the most amazing women I've ever met
like high school teacher no like
preschool teacher whoa yeah and she saw
this propensity for learning and this
potential in me and fostered it and
really pushed me and and presented
education as discovery and joy and a way
to kind of uncover the world around you
and so with my entire life I've looked
at education in that way and I've looked
at school as something fun something
exciting and my mom and grandmother and
everybody continued to foster that in me
as I was going through school and so
that's something that it's always made
learning fun yeah it's always made
school joyful yeah that perspective that
the framework of Education makes it seem
like it's a privilege rather than a task
yeah you get the opportunity to expand
your brain rather than you have to do
this certain thing exactly that's very
cool
exactly so I've always loved school I
was a huge math nerd growing up which is
why I ended up sort of in economics
because I loved with math especially
higher math that it's it's like a puzzle
to figure out it's a being of the soul
that we're gonna move there's an answer
somewhere in there you just have to find
it there's a finite answer you had this
amorphous and then once I discovered
that those formulas and graphs and
thought processes could be used to apply
and explain these phenomena of the world
in economics that fascinated me even
more so then I decided I wanted to go
into developmental economics which I did
pursue I ended up getting my degree what
does that mean developmental economics
yeah if you could make it down through
what I will call the dumb asses like
myself of the world
how do you describe what that field is
are you ready for me to nerd out for a
minute I'm bracing myself basically we
exist in a world that has different
levels of countries as they're
developing so you have the giant huge
countries of the world the control most
of the global economy and then you have
these developing countries that are
building momentum quickly but need
capital in order to get a solid footing
okay so developmental economics it sort
of combines economics and anthropology
in a way where you it's very specific
and very it's it's all down to the
minutiae of each situation which is why
I loved it so much because you go into
these countries and you help them figure
out ways to set up economic structures
and to set up their systems in a way
that will help use the capital from
these developed countries to build them
but not to a point where they will be
inhibited by their relationships with
the bigger country so that they can
eventually have a sense of ownership
over what they're doing and they can
become it more independent as they grow
Kath if someone told me that when I woke
up at 7:00 a.m. this morning I would
have a lesson on developmental economics
I would not have believed thank you are
you interested
do you watch Shark Tank I do from time
to time there's that fascinate you I
mean you must understand it on a level
because I've been obsessed with shark
tank recently and I do not know much
about the finances business etc that
must like equate to you on a different
level that must must speak a language to
you that I can't speak I do love it
whenever I check it out that and then
there's a UK version as well then we're
seeing from time to time I have Co not
Dragons Den Wow yes it's all dragons day
really went there I'm not sure which
existed first but they went there yeah
so that's it's really fun to see it and
I also I'm a huge fan of those kind of
products just to see what people are
innovating and coming up with it's
fascinating I've found out that I have
accidentally bought like six shark tank
products and going back and re watching
episodes absolutely oh so I'm yeah I'm
feeding the dragon basically well you
should okay
now obviously use this wonderfully rich
economic educational background
what shifts to acting where where does
this happen and how do you even tell
your parents I feel like this is like a
confession that you need to tell your
parents of like I'm so sorry but I want
to be an actress well this is how it
happened it's very funny I always say I
fell into it backwards because I never
intended to pursue anything like this as
a career when I was a kid but I was a
ballet dancer from the time I was very
small it was something I loved it was my
outlet my escape and your artistry
exactly yeah and so I ended up running
into a family friend who was directing a
community-theater show and needed a
dancer and I was a kid who would try
anything so I said well sure let me give
this a go it'll be interesting something
new you see what happens I walked on
stage on opening night and it was one of
those rare moments of clarity that you
get in look where suddenly everything
stopped
everything was so crystal clear and I
something hit me like a brick wall and I
just knew that I was put on this earth
to tell stories like a lightning rod yep
a lightning rod I kid you not and I have
never looked back how old were you when
this happened I think I was about 12
Wow so pretty early on yeah but I mean
the most transformative years of your
life exactly this is the clarity that I
mean I think everyone's searching for
clarity but I was lucky my family was
actually really supportive of it in that
they said well as long as you you know
get a college education pursue your
dreams see what happens that's what they
said education and you can do this as
well
yeah and I think one of the most
gratifying things over the last several
years as my career has kind of gotten
more momentum and and I have things that
have a bit more longevity happening it's
my family's now started to see it more
as a career and not as that thing that
I'm doing before I actually settle down
and have a career yeah this like
flippant thing that is you know just
she's having a moment I know it's like
oh I get that this is a career because
where I'm from and in the
kind of family that I'm from things
creative aren't necessarily we don't I
didn't even know being an actor was a
job when I was a kid I didn't know that
was a job that somebody could do I
didn't wasn't quite sure how it happened
but I knew the amorphous state of acting
existed it was you know a job that
somebody dead as my whole career and
it's just not something people think
about you know and so as I as this
career happened and as my family learned
more about it they kind of went oh wow
this is actually really cool and
something very interesting and and can
turn into something real and and it's
it's been kind of amazing to see that
have they
what was the have you brought them out
to LA to see certain steps in your
career like was there one kind of moment
where you brought your parents out that
they could actually like visualize and
see like the success that you've had
they visited from time to time but I
didn't really take people to a set until
the Shadowhunters set because I wanted
to have something that was like
established and write mine and it was
you know something that it was my home I
could show them and my grandparents
loved Shadowhunters they did they
watched it every week your grandparents
yeah and so my grandparents my mom came
to visit me in Toronto right before we
shot the series finale episode and I was
able to take them through the set and
kind of show them everything that had
been built over the last four years I
mean yeah literally like you're taking
them to your house I have a crib store
of like welcome to my crib it was so
wonderful because they I got to
introduce them to so many people who do
my family and it was amazing to watch
them discover the set in the way that I
had discovered it the first time so I'll
never forget the first time I walked
onto that set yeah because they had
built it and we had just done the first
table raid and they were all excited to
show us yeah we were all together as a
group brand-new fresh off the boat
little baby was coming coming into our
brand-new show not knowing anything that
was about to happen to us and I remember
walking into the Institute set which was
this big kind of headquarters for the
Shadowhunters and there were glass and
screens and all these old church walls
and it was I
of our Batcave yeah and we walked on the
set and I I was speechless instantly it
was so grand it was so beautiful and
well done and just beyond my imagination
and it was real like this is real
happening yeah and I knew from that
point forward that that that set was
gonna be something special I mean it
became a character in and of itself just
like the entire cast and crew did yeah
have you well.one do do your mom and
your your grandmother have affinities
towards certain members of the cast
actually they because they're my Big
Brother's I think no it's - it's it's
funny cuz I'll the the boys give me
trouble about things all the time and my
mom has a great sense of humor so she'll
come to set and she's gotten to know a
couple of them where she can do the same
with them and it's funny to watch them
do a double-take cuz my my mom has a
great sense of humor oh that's great and
also she's coming from such an
educational background she's like I
don't know what you guys do with all of
them exactly exactly
you guys must have become such an insane
family after that it's been four years
in total
yeah yeah that's a college education it
was it sort of was my college years
because I you know I graduated
University when I was 17 and a very busy
thing for everyone to do and aspire to
do good luck it doesn't happen to
everyone
only good brains do it but what what
that left is when I started at book
Shadowhunters when I was 19 that's
bonkers
it was pretty bunkers and so I'm you
remember the call there you got I know
vividly yeah basically they had
announced on Twitter that they were
gonna say who Clary was in two hours and
I still hadn't heard anything when they
announced on Twitter on the
Shadowhunters Twitter because they were
building there was something because of
the webseries this is such modern social
media this is nuts
it was amazing well because the book
series had such a following people
wanted to know who was being cast yes
the show was being developed and they
were announcing us character by
character and I knew it was between me
and one of the other actress uh-huh and
they said okay in two hours hash
who was Clary who's it gonna be so you
were following along with everyone else
and I had I didn't know and so I assumed
that it wasn't me and so I said no no
this is no it's not yeah so I saw that
and I went oh okay well it must have not
gone my way cuz I don't I haven't heard
anything yet so that's fine that's
wonderful for her happy for her you have
to be it that way right and so I get a
phone call saying hey wait a second we
haven't heard anything they haven't said
who it is they haven't announced it yet
to even us nobody's teams have heard
anything so just hold tight and so I'm
going okay so then I'm waiting and I'm
waiting I'm nervous and I already know
the outcome of this story and who is
Clary is trending on Twitter and there's
all of these things happening and I'm
sitting here going but I still haven't
heard anything so I go to the gym
because I'm like I have to do something
ten minutes before the two hours is up I
get a phone call and they say
congratulations you will be playing
Clary Fairchild in the Mortal
Instruments Shadowhunters show we are so
excited to have you bubble blah and oh
by the way can you sing over to ABC
Family offices we have ten minutes for
you to say yes to this so that we can
announce it pretty much and then it was
announced and then I had ten minutes
where I I just didn't know what to think
because the entire world was about to
find out and this fandom that had such
opinions and was so excited and I was
just hoping that I hope they are okay
with it being me well I mean there's so
much joy mmm pressure at the same time
but I have to say they gave me the
warmest welcome the the fandom and it's
been that way ever since and it's been
the biggest joy getting to go on this
journey with them and create this story
and having them be such a part of it
it's been so lovely oh that's so cool
okay we're gonna take a quick break I
want to get more into the fandom arrow
shared a Shadowhunter everything we're
just scratching the surface we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
we have support from Buffy today Buffy
makes bedding that is earth friendly and
cruelty-free their products are made
using only sustainable and recycled
materials which makes them as soft on
the planet as they are on your bed their
latest product the breeze is a comforter
made entirely from 100% eucalyptus fiber
to regulate temperature and keep you
cool and comfortable all night long it
regulates temperature which means no
more night sweats as someone that
occasionally gets night sweats I can't
help it it happens when you're an adult
I guess this has been a godsend the
breeze is made of eucalyptus fabric
inside and out it's softer than cotton
and naturally soothes skin it's also
hypoallergenic in fact its high thread
count shuts out dust mold and mites for
a healthier sleeping environment they
also offer a free trial you can try a
comforter in your own bed for free and
if you don't love it or turn it at no
cost
I have almost the entire collection of
Buffy products I've got the breeze I've
got the other comforter that I can't
remember the name of off the top of my
head I also have their eucalyptus sheets
which I highly recommend
I love all of it and why not choose 100%
plant-based bedding that's better for
you and the earth and you guys can get
$20 off your Buffy comforter by visiting
Buffy CO and entering the code
NTD that's Buffy CO buffy CEO and code
NTD for $20 off your Buffy comforter we
are back so I want to talk about like
the social media phenomenon of all of
these shows that you are involved in
were you involved in social media
leading up to these shows like did you I
mean obviously we all have Facebook's we
all have Twitter's whatever but like I'm
sure this show really kind of thrust you
into a place of now I need to
participate in social media for sure
I mean I've done some work with Disney
Channel back in the day and did some
with The Maze Runner movie series
garnered a little bit of traction in
that yeah but it wasn't until
Shadowhunters that thing
kind of exploded from that first moment
and since then it's just been a rolling
machine but I in with arrow as well
these fandoms are so fierce and they're
so passionate so engaged and it's insane
what a gift that is though yeah because
you know so often we pour our blood
sweat and tears into things and it goes
out into the world and people go oh yeah
that's cool yeah but if one person
actually connects with what you're doing
it's like the most incredible feeling
absolutely and because I've been so
close with the Shadowhunters fans for
years it's it's been really incredible
to watch them grow because it started
with the book fans and with the book in
the movie fans and then the TV show fans
came in and it just blossomed into this
beautiful thing and because of the
diversity of the characters in our show
being in race and sexuality and
relationships and every every aspect and
we pretty much have everything in
Shadowhunters Oh which is why I love it
so much if there's something for
everyone exactly and people connect so
much with it and I think the reason for
that is you know the mythology of our
show I'm gonna get a little fan to be on
you for once please because everyone
that's listening to this for you wants
this moment so in the world of
Shadowhunters
we have angels and demons and and
werewolves warlocks fairies shadow
hunters everything they all exist on a
scale from angel to human to demon we're
Shadowhunters our half angel half human
Wow isn't that such a human scale too ya
know
so shadow hundreds are half angel half
human warlocks are half demon half human
fairies are half angel half demon and
we're or yeah werewolves and vampires
are humans with a demon disease so
everybody kind of exists within that
gray area this is some Carl Jung Freud
[ __ ] right now kind of what this the
whole message of the story is is that no
matter what kind of blood you have
coursing through your veins no matter
what you were born no matter what you
become it's the choices that you make it
make you who you are and make you a hero
or or a villain mm-hmm and that kind of
messaging has sort of spawned the fans
have taken that on as their own mission
and it's they've created beyond our
characters beyond the story beyond us
they
become this kind of community and this
movement that just celebrates love and
acceptance and being and expressing your
true self and I've seen them support not
just us but each other in their art and
in their personal struggles because I'm
create a community in which they can all
like yes they did it all we just got to
be with really but it's it's incredible
to see the sort of force of positivity
and love exists globally I am in I mean
this will air in 2020 that's what we
need when are you writing your self-help
book when can i pre-order it what's
happening I feel like this is the
obvious next step as well in the
Marriott of other things I'm doing I'll
just go ahead and write a self-help book
I mean I feel like is an amazing title
for a self up book I'm putting out there
- your publicist that's sitting to the
left and just you know putting it out
into the ether perfect speaking this is
an insane fandom I want to know a little
bit about because it's so intense for a
brain to process like all of a sudden
going from like Kansas City to now I'm
in this you know a world in which people
have created this entire fandom etc what
are Comic Cons or conventions like for
you they are the most wonderfully
inspiring humbling and exhausting things
that I ever did but in the best way I
love them it's the sweetest energy of
all time it's just a bunch of people
aggressively loving things
exactly exactly well that's why I love
the multi fandom cons as well because
you get to go and see people get so
excited over everything and all in Haas
play and everybody's just there to
celebrate things that they love yes
which is awesome
but then I've been to a lot of
Shadowhunters specific conventions as
well which are argue maybe more fun
sometimes cuz we just get to kind of run
amok and you get each other's panels and
have so much fun but it's really amazing
to connect with the fans in that way
because you get to talk to people and
hear their stories and look at their art
in person and just see them interact not
only with us but with each other
I've had people come up to me and go I'm
so excited today because I'm meeting my
best friend for the first time in person
we've been talking on Twitter for two
years and they're here today and I never
saw a dental matchmaker and it's so fun
oh that's so sweet it's really amazing
to kind of just feel this energy have
you ever had a fangirl moment with
someone at a convention or even on a red
carpet or anything like that I've had
I've had a few I got a few I think the
one bit I always think of because it was
just I can be an awkward human welcome
to the club I will never forget it was
one of my first times going to the whole
Golden Globes after-party situation
running around to all the different
events where there's just everybody
there you're seeing all of these people
I was walking through chatting with a
friend and out of the corner of my eye I
just happened to see this glow and I
wasn't sure what it was I look and it
was Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively
through the party and something came
over me I just stopped I just went to
just a neutral position I think my jaw
hit the floor and I just stared pretty
sure I made awkward eye contact with
Blake Lively sure just staring and
following the intent and then suddenly
the spell was broken when I couldn't see
them anymore and I went about trying to
figure out where I was but that was that
was pretty amazing aura they truly did
oh my goodness let's talk about music
what's going on there it's not the
question
there's no it's it's funny because the
the showrunners of Shadowhunters found
out that i did music right because it's
you know in the rest of my career I'm
playing a character and it's someone
else's words and someone else's shoes
that I'm living in yeah so music for me
is my one outlet where I can put a
little piece of my heart and soul the
world yeah and it's terrifying me
vulnerable but in the most wonderful way
yeah so I it's at something that I
really love and I sent them a few of my
songs because they wanted to hear them
mm-hmm and they said oh this one we love
we want to put it on the soundtrack of
the season finale this year I said okay
thank you and it was released and people
really like responded to it and it was
in the top 100 on iTunes that week and I
was floored by the response uh-huh but I
had been so long since I'd actually
focused on music I didn't have anything
to follow I cannot fight my inner demons
to make music right now exactly so
having in the song was called ember
having ember out there has been great
and seeing people respond to it and
seeing people really get excited about
it it's great so now that I'm not
fighting demons ten months a year and I
have a little bit more time on my hands
I'm digging back into music you are yeah
I am which is great I'm so excited I I
got to dabble a little bit this year in
that I was a part of the there's a
Netflix series called spirit riding free
and they did a Christmas special called
the spirit of Christmas and you're a
voice in it and I'm a voice in it I play
a singer-songwriter named Sally Jessup
what a what a stretch it was super fun I
got to go back to my Southern roots and
got to sing some really really wonderful
Christmas songs that's awesome
and so is this a thing on the horizon
potentially to be more work done the
music side of things yeah 100% it's
something that I've I have so many songs
that are just on my computer that are
half finished or finished or I have a
bunch of them out there I've almost had
a halloween EP like three times
Halloween yeah really mm-hmm and it's
just been a matter of paperwork but it
hasn't gotten done this is the thing
that everyone wants yeah I mean who
Mariah Carey his own Christmas right but
no one's on Halloween well say it'll be
interesting now it's your time it is
time it wasn't did cat the one thing I
really want to ask you about because you
are incredibly busy and your brain does
a beautiful thing what do you do in your
free time how do you relax
a couple things okay um fitness has
become a huge part of my life since
starting Shadowhunters well you must
have to do stunt training and all of
that for the show
exactly I've been a dancer my whole life
so I've always been an athlete but I'd
sort of written off any potential for
real physical strength for myself
given that I'm a tiny human I have
written off physical strength as an
attribute when the apocalypse happens
I'm going to be emotionally supporting
everyone no but I then I started
Shadowhunters and I met all these
amazing trainers and they said no no you
absolutely can be incredibly strong and
fit and do all of these things we just
have to show you how and they did and it
completely changed my world what changed
my life it changed how I feel it changed
my body it truly was kind of a
revolution for me yeah and so that
mind-body connection
exactly it's kind of become my me time
yeah I I either go to a spin class or I
go box or I go for a run or I just go to
the gym and lift every single day I try
and do something cuz it just clears my
head
that's great puts me in the right space
to do whatever it is else that I need to
do that day I'm on the same boat that
like I run as my like relief and I think
I love it because I can't be on my phone
I can't talk to other people it's
literally just me and my
in my body and that's the most kind of
relieving thing yeah yeah they listen to
podcasts or that's why you run yeah it's
my favorite thing
see I listen to jock jams to each their
own
so that's that's something I do in my
free time I also love to travel
yeah it's something that you know I I'm
often in one place doing a job or
popping in and out here and there but I
love learning about the world by seeing
it and experiencing how other people
live their lives and just going to
beautiful places taking incredible
pictures my best friend's a photographer
as well so we we just love to travel to
beautiful places and take pictures and
experience the culture I mean what a
great job for a best friend incredible
pictures where's a place you haven't
traveled to yet that's on your short
list oh I'm dying to go to Indonesia and
I know Seychelles I'd really like to
have never been to Hawaii something
simple with Hawaii yeah Ben that seems
like an easy get mm-hmm an easy go to
pretty much everywhere I haven't been no
I'd like to go it's it's the extravagant
things and the simple things the
extravagant things like these grand
trips that I love to plan am i yeah but
also some things that I love doing in my
free time is just sitting with family
and friends or some people I love
however you don't define that and having
a wonderful game night I'm just sitting
down and laughing we're coming around
yeah but game night is one of my
favorite things because it you can't
help but laugh you're gonna have a good
time it can be any I mean I love mafia I
love running sureiy okay okay
what else do I love to play at linky
have you ever heard of lanky no but it
sounds like a cute app it's wonderful
it's it's sort of a category game where
you answer four questions and they all
lead to in response and you have to get
anyway it's a long story but it's a
wonderful game you do you watch
television I mean you're on it so much
do you actually watch it I do yeah
what do you watch i watch a lot of
things actually okay I kind of keep it
on in the background
I'm doing other things yeah it's my
music what did I just finally I'm so
behind though like just finished
watching fleabag see I haven't even
gotten to though you must I know I'm
here there are very few series that I
would attribute to being perfect series
like Mad Men is one yeah Breaking Bad as
another yes we bag is another it is one
of the most poignant smart funny
heartwarming heartbreaking series I
watched two episodes on a plane because
that was all that was available and it
teased me to no end and they know that I
have to emotionally prepare myself if
I'm gonna finish the series because it
is that enriching and that like engaging
I had watched one episode a long time
ago and then finally circled back to it
and I watched the rest of them in 24
hours I do not stop watching see that's
how I am with the great british baking
show that so many times you're a baker
and you don't want a great bridge baking
shot well you might be offended by it
because i don't bake at all so that's
why i can indulge in it but I feel like
Baker's might be like a little more
sensitive a recreational Baker but I
think I think I would enjoy other than
fleabag anything else you're watching
currently I'm currently watching season
3 of mrs. basil and about that yeah it's
so lovely what else do i watch i'm tryin
yeah oh my god have you seen it
yeah and it's real good so good it's
real good and it makes me mad but when i
watch it because it's so good are
incredible on it and i get I have to
like stamp my boyfriend i watch it acted
like stand up and walk around the room
because I'm just like so aggressively
like intensely into every person's
character to me watching succession is
like eating at a Michelin star
restaurant I don't deserve this little
tiny bites and then that's it yeah it's
gone
more oh so okay quick question before we
take one last break and answer some
Twitter questions what's like a dream
role that you a character that you'd
want to play Oh a dream character that I
want to play or like give you what it's
kind of silly but I can give you one
so the Broadway show that I did which is
the job that took me out of Kansas City
is a little night music mhm and it's one
of my favorite shows but what's so
special about it is it has characters
for women kind of at every age okay and
so I played the youngest character in
the show who's she's 12 I was 14 when I
did the show well that's what a reach
but I with some incredible women on it
and there's a character that's this my
characters grandmother uh-huh and it was
played by Angela Lansbury and then
Elaine Stritch when I did the show and
those women are my heroes they told you
everything I know they saved me I
literally and figuratively but I would
love to play Madame Armfeldt one day in
a Little Night Music if it were ever to
come back okay
94 Lane was 94 when she did the show Wow
so I I'm dying to play Madame Armfeldt
when I'm 94 all right well if there's
still time wait 50 years what happens
okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back we have a bunch of
Twitter questions for you because as you
know this fandom is engaged with
everything that you're up to so I'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
it is time to turn your dream into a
reality with guess who Squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project are you looking to start
a new business do you want to showcase
your work do you want to publish content
or sell products or more Squarespace is
the tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks so
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself plus they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online and analytics that
help you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade buying domains is simple and
you can get the help that you need with
their 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people designers
lawyers artists gamers even restaurants
and gyms to turn great ideas into
something real so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace okay we're back before
we get into these Twitter questions I'm
going to ask you the two questions asked
every single guest okay that is on the
podcast but first is who alive or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti act throw cold spaghetti at
hmm alive or dead doesn't necessarily
have to be a negative thing it can be
celebratory if you choose entirely up to
you it can be negative you know I think
mmm yeah this question really boggles a
lot of people's brains it's I am
consider me boggled I would like to
throw cold spaghetti at and it can also
change day to day so this is your answer
today it can change tomorrow okay so
it's not definitive okay
this is how I know that you have a very
intelligent brain is that yeah I can
literally like that meme of a beautiful
there is so much happening in your brain
that you know work out if you like
you're doing a quadratic equation right
now oh yeah I'm sorry okay I'll just
pick something I would like to throw
cold spaghetti at I actually rather like
cold spaghetti Julie it's actually quite
quite yummy it's my favorite form of
spaghetti yeah cold leftovers it's like
cold pizza but in middle form thank you
thank you okay my boyfriend thinks it's
disgusting no I am trying to prove that
it is the best way to go no no no not I
am also an enjoyer of cold leftover
thank you
um actually instead of throwing cold
spaghetti at someone I would like to
invite you to a cold spaghetti food
fight in which we can also eat the cold
spaghetti this is the first time we've
had this answer on not to date we've had
200 plus episodes Wow I RSVP to that
food okay the other question that I ask
every single guest is to tell us your
worst pants shooting story we're close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases or a combination so
for instance mine is college jogging
front lawn exactly yeah
so if you have a place that you can
describe to us in three small phrases
mm-hmm mine would be bad chicken oh car
la traffic every single person in this
room can relate
thank goodness for squats because I've I
have you know kegels and squats do one
bit
alright let's get into these Twitter
questions someone snow before she had
her own costume on arrow whose superhero
suit did she want to steal because I
always joke about this with someone I
always threatened to steal Superman's
cape because then you can fly anywhere
and get there quickly that's you know
airline travel is a wonderful thing but
also takes so much time it's so much and
also I mean we just spoke about la
traffic if we all had that availability
mm-hmm I think we'd alleviate the
highways but I do have to say the that
watching them build my aero suit was
incredible there's such that like it was
amazing because I got to you know I was
there for the fitting yeah that had to
be on my body yeah it was incredible
because there's they've done so many and
they've done so many so well that
they're such masters and the their
creativity when it comes to detail is
the most amazing thing your for example
on my suit you you can't see it in most
of the shots but it's made of this
material called uro Jersey which is like
this really thin stretchy fabric but
they had those stuff for my suit printed
with little teeny tiny arrowheads all
over in two different patterns so my
entire suit is made up of little teeny
tiny arrows so that's like a thing for
you yeah oh that's so cool it's really
cool because their whole idea was to
base it off of Oliver's suit but make it
kind of new and a little more feminine
but then also how does it make it arrow
theme to have everything be an arrow so
every kind of shape is slightly bad like
an arrowhead or yeah that's super cool
that's amazing
also I think it's very cool when they
make women's superhero suits in a
practical sense right but it's not like
here's my tits out and like I look hot
but like here I can fight crime and like
kill bad guys and do cool things it's
awesome and it's so much fun to wear as
well because you you feel like a
superhero yeah you put on the suit you
look around and there's you know a
couple super men in the flash and
Supergirl
the cool kids now this is great I made
the cut look at me yeah but it kind of
makes you want to run around and jump
and do cool things yeah there you want
to parkour immediately so I have to give
a shout out to Stephen Amell because in
season 1 of arrow he kind of he and the
wardrobe department created this concept
for the boots ok obviously they have to
look like big hardcore boots but he had
the idea cuz he like myself does a lot
of our own stunts yeah of going well
it's gonna be so impractical to have
those heavy boots all the time right
can we take the soul of a Nike or some
kind of sneaker and put it make a boot
on top of it and they went well yeah
sure
so my superhero boots are basically
sneakers running shoes ok how have you
guys like marketed this wow I mean this
take this - Shark Tank right take it to
the icing it take it to Spencer's gifts
just say golf boots but you can run in
yeah
no but I have to leave a shout-out to
Steven for that because that is a
godsend that's amazing it also helps you
perform better because you're not just
clunking around in a bunch of heavy
boots yeah it makes me want to jump over
things someone to know Philip wants to
know I'm graduating college on Friday
what advice do you have for the future
first of all congratulations it's a huge
accomplishment and not an easy one so
kudos to you pat yourself on the back
yeah I'm just a light-hearted easy
question to answer
treat yourself first of all second of
all I would say be open to unorthodox
opportunities that you wouldn't
necessarily expect you because the way
the job market is now I've seen a lot of
my friends struggle and figuring out
where to go and what to do because it's
not an easy market always know no matter
what your industry is mm-hmm so just
leave yourself open whatever your field
is to doing something kind of unexpected
and making your own way we live in a
world with the internet now where you
can do so much and create so many of
your own opportunities yeah
be open to that yeah there's no
traditional path anymore I also feel
like and maybe you resonate with this is
like
find collaborators find people that you
admire and kind of use their path as
inspiration absolutely yeah which is
kind of the coolest thing in the
universe to find people that you
actually really love and admire Alisha
want to know if you could spend a day
with any fictional character who would
it be Sherlock Holmes really mm-hmm
I'm a huge fanatic I grew up reading the
books so they loved every I think I've
read pretty much every Sherlock Holmes
story that stars are Conan Doyle wrote
but I just I love the character he's a
superhero to me yeah just the fact that
he can create such inferences from the
most mundane of details yeah in things I
just put the way he his powers of
deduction our superpowers to me do you
find any interest in other like CSI type
shows I do okay I went on a huge when I
was a teenager I went on a huge Criminal
Minds bin oh yeah
and I watched I think my mom was a
little worried about me it's like she's
an artist I don't know yeah she was into
dance and now she's in the criminal
psyche that fascinate the human psyche
yeah it's me and that's kind of why I
love being an actor too yeah as we get a
script and that's sort of we have all
the information we have the A to Z we
have all the details in there but then
we have to figure out the why mm-hm and
we have to figure out what takes that
person and why they make those choices
and what makes them make those decisions
and why it is specifically that their
perspective causes them to see the world
in that way oh that's so cool and the
fact that we get to create all of these
characters and and discover who these
people are and figure out why they are
the way they are it's fascinating to me
well I don't know why you haven't
started writing the female Sherlock
Holmes for yourself I feel like that is
also all knocking on all the wood I mean
I do have to say Benedict Cumberbatch
did it pretty well but there's gotta be
there's got to be
he's gonna have a kid out there
somewhere in real life or on the show
I mean Sherlock Holmes oh you're not
breaking newness no Benedict Benedict
Cumberbatch's better to come a rat
what's your favorite memory from the
arrow set that's probably hard to choose
it's very hard to choose I would say one
of my favorite memories from the arrow
set was it's sort of bittersweet it's
it's yeah it's a terrific one cuz
there's so many of them there was one
day in particular when we were shooting
the final final episode that pretty much
everybody was on set uh-huh and
everybody came and even people that
weren't working that day showed up he
has so many people were rapping right
around that same time and it it hadn't
really felt real for me because we did
you know the backdoor pilot and we did
all these other things that it didn't
feel as though I was fully saying
goodbye to this world right and that
made it so not final but it made me
realize that it will never be the same
Oh in that moment yeah and it just it
hit me because there's been so much love
on that set and it's been so wonderful
and it's funny because I had a very
similar moment on the set of
Shadowhunters during when we finished
the the series finale of Shadowhunters
we our final scene everybody was on set
it was the big Malick wedding where you
know we had people coming in from all
storylines all seasons everybody was
there yeah we were having the rat party
on our stages because we were just gonna
run them up and celebrate and have a
good time and I remember we just wrapped
done the champagne toast everybody
applauded and then everybody went to go
change for the party and I'm walking to
the edge of this soundstage and I
stopped at the edge of the set and I
realized that it's the last moment that
I'm going to be walking off set in
character as the last time as Clary ever
and I didn't I didn't want to move I
turned to Brian who is our head makeup
artist cuz he was the only one kind of
still there and I said Brian I'd I don't
want to go I had a Tom
but I would say you know I did and the
party was wonderful and we all tried but
those kind of moments always stick with
me when you realize that it's not
goodbye but it's never gonna be the same
yeah yeah yeah but it's also really
wonderful to have those moments of like
present reflection mm-hmm present like
encouragement and like appreciation for
those things cuz otherwise everything
passes you by like you know cars on a
highway and they you never appreciate it
especially in in our world where we have
the one constant is that a project is
going to end eventually right any will
have to move on to something else right
and it's you know you get so close with
people and you become such a family
because you spend so much time and so
much time with these people moments and
you you really see each other at your
best in your worst and that brings you
together and it's true I mean it's hard
to I'm sure for you to really really
describe what it's like to be on those
kind of sets because it really is you're
spending 16 hours a day with these
people and to the people that you love
and you're you know
personal life you're spending an hour
with maybe if you're lucky yeah it's so
like the pie chart of how much time you
spend with these people is absolutely
insane yeah and it's true well and it's
it's even more of a gift when you get to
work with people that you really care
about and you can enjoy spending time
with and it does become a family from
the cast to the crew to everybody on
that set yeah both arrow and shadow
hunters I've been really fortunate to
have such positive experiences I can not
wait for what next okay let's get into a
last question here I'm trying to find
the best last question well here's a
second to last question okay as a Casey
native what's your favorite barbecue
spot Oh see there's it's really hard to
choose I mean gates is amazing Oklahoma
Joe's is incredible Oklahoma Joe's are
special because it's in it's in a gas
station in the middle of nowhere in
Kansas I mean you don't have to ask me
twice about getting food from a gas
station in New Jersey
promote my meals come from well Arthur
Bryant's to its classic there's so many
incredible places in Kansas City you
really can't go wrong I went back there
for there's a bunch of amazing actors
and comedians that are all from Kansas
City and they do this thing called the
big slick every year where it's all it's
a huge charity event to benefit the
Children's Hospital and over the last
ten years they've raised over ten
million dollars for the hospital amazing
in in one weekend last year we raised
2.5 million dollars it's incredible what
they do but it all ended this year with
a big variety show in the five thousand
seat Stadium in Kansas City after that
they had they brought in a bunch of the
top barbecue spots in Kansas City to
feed everybody we're all hungry and
tired all that and I realized I hadn't
had proper KC barbecue in a very long
time do you know what burnt ends are
burnt turned ends it's it's a can I say
barbecue special it's sort of the end of
the brisket we're kind of just falls
apart and it can infer what they I think
it is it's really like melts in your
mouth covered in sauce it's gorgeous I
think I had three full plates of bread
from all of these places welcome home ok
cat last question what is up for you in
2020 what's going on what can people
expect what can people look forward to
what sort of teases can you put out
there what's exciting is that there are
so many possibilities for what's going
to happen there are some things right
now I'm in the middle of shooting
Stephen King's The Stand which is gonna
be a lot of fun a very light-hearted
family-friendly film for CBS all access
it's a 9 episode miniseries and the cast
is insane and everybody who's working on
it really is passionate about Stephen
King and about the project it's it's
such animate its such a departure for me
from what I've been doing and the
character as well it's such a departure
cool so that's very exciting I'm sure
your fans will love to see that I'm not
sure when it's coming out I assume 2020
at some point Google it absolutely
and then we'll see about the the
backdoor pilot we'll find out sometime
dear if it's moving forward into series
and if not I have some other irons in
the fire that who will say some really
exciting things I'm dipping my toe into
producing and into back into music like
we talked about and directing as well
amazing so I've got some irons in the
fire in all of those fields and I'm
dying to dig in that's so cool and for
people that don't know where can they
find you
across the board social media wise
twitter is cat underscore mcnamara
instagram is cat mcnamara cat everyone
that makes time to be a guest on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie personalized to you you're
welcome to open it I would recommend not
eating it but you can read the fortune
that's inside I have a weird thing about
fortune cookies Oh
in my family we as somebody else always
like cracks the fortune cookie for it
would you crack the fortune cookie says
this is a first yeah absolutely
wow that's um your family is an
interesting family out of here with my
fingernails it's yeah we don't make it
easy for our guests all right if you
would like to read it out loud
they'll be a wonderful as someone as
smart and talented as you you guys are
too nice we think it's perhaps best that
you tell us what the winning lottery
numbers are please enunciate and repeat
the numbers in case we miss than the
first time around yep
you know what I'll have to consult Sarah
Lance and/or Barry Allen on that because
they're the experts in time travel there
and I'll get back to you i'll you know
portal myself fair and come back and
then we'll take our winnings and make
our Shark Tank products oh it all works
out twenty twenty get ready things are
gonna be different
thank you again for being here this was
so fun thank you I had a blast we'll see
you guys next time on another episode of
not too deep goodbye too deep today
Totti not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa Dee months
camera operator Katrina Henning
edited by Shireen Lana unis post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]